[Música]
Blanca la verdad yo ya viví esto en el
85 eso es un susto muy berraco Entonces
ya estamos acostumbrados aquí ya estamos
acostumbrados a todos Ya que botes de
Niza que
bote ceniza y arena y ya ya nos
acostumbramos nosotros
[Música]
se han reportado ruidos en la parte
Norte del volcán eso está dentro de lo
normal de un volcán que está en esta
condición y no cambia la condición de
que haya una probabilidad de erupción en
términos de días o semanas
[Música]
el ejército ha desplegado también los
ingenieros militares para mejorar las
vías en las cuales hay población
concentrada que necesita de evacuar en
las zonas de más alto riesgo
[Música]